it may take months to determine the
cause of the crash but many people are
asking why the chopper was flying in
dense fog especially since other
choppers had been grounded the rate of
helicopter crashes has decreased over
the past two decades but there have been
around 20 deadly accidents in the US
every year since 2013 Kris Van Cleave is
near the crash site in Calabasas
California
Kris good morning to you what else are
investigators looking at to determine
how this chopper went down
well good morning NTSB investigators
will be back out here on the scene
behind me once the Sun gets up and
really everything is still on the table
for investigators they are poring
through the pilots history through the
maintenance history of this helicopter
working to better understand the weather
conditions up here and they're also
going to start working to recover some
of the wreckage they want to look at the
helicopters engines try to determine if
anything mechanically went wrong but
this was a helicopter that had a very
good safety history and I was sitting in
traffic I wanted to missing like a
school play because out sitting in
traffic in 2018 Kobe Bryant talked about
why he started flying in helicopters I
had to figure out a way where I could
still train and focus on the craft but
still not compromised family time and so
that's when I looked into helicopters
didn't be able to get down and back in
15 minutes
Bryant his daughter Gigi and seven
others were on their way to Kobe's Mambo
Sports Academy the pilot aras abuyin who
was experienced with more than 8200
flight hours began flying under normal
visual flight rules or VFR which
typically requires about three miles of
visibility about 14 minutes into the
flight
Subbaiah Nast air traffic control for
special VFR allowing him to fly in
worsening weather with less visibility
it is not unusual in Los Angeles to have
less than three miles visibility
aviation consultant William Lawrence is
a retired Marine Corps colonel and flew
helicopters in the LA area for years and
if he didn't have special VFR you pretty
much wouldn't be able to fly NTSB board
member Jennifer Hamid II says in the
flights final moments the pilot told
air-traffic control he was going to try
to get above the worsening weather the
chopper then climbed into the clouds
turn
and entered a steep dive my
understanding is that the company
operates under VFR and the fact that at
least at the end it looks like the pilot
would have left VFR to get above the
clouds then is an interesting question
to have answer yeah we'll have to look
at that but it's too early to know why
the helicopter crashed and why so many
lives were cut short it still could be a
mechanical failure it could be the pilot
got disoriented it could be that the fog
played a part in it both the LAPD and LA
County Sheriff had grounded their
helicopter fleets because of the weather
on Sunday news helicopters weren't
flying because of the weather now this
morning the NTSB released this photo of
investigators preparing a drone that
they have put up over the crash scene to
map the crash scene we understand in the
coming days the Safety Board expects to
have to bring in a helicopter to airlift
some of the wreckage off the crash scene
it's very remote so they want to get
that to a place where they can look at
it more safely Anthony president Cleve
thank you Chris